[Music]
so
since everybody was asking over there
hey guys a lot of people have been
asking us about the gavin mcginnis
get supposedly being arrested and
detained by the feds and well that's
what that's what josh danny reported
that's what josh danny said it's what a
lot of people were saying gavin took
some phone call that he was off the
screen for a half hour
and
you know whatever everybody was calling
me everybody speculate he hasn't tweeted
he hasn't said anything to anybody all
weekend someone's like oh [ __ ] he's in
jail the fed's got gavin
um
oh oh owens owen's been in a [ __ ]
redemption arc lately uh
i
owns a [ __ ] oh and poor gasoline on
the whole thing and set it on fire
we don't need a setup he kind of
explains it in this clip oh yeah okay
let's see here we go
let's see owens redemption arc
i never told this guy i was gonna keep
this as a secret i'm not even gonna say
his name but i'm gonna tell the story
and if you you can probably figure it
out
so i'm getting all these uh dms of like
did you hear about this guy the fbi just
raided his apartment or his studio
and all these bears are like extra
scared because they were part of his
like um
little gay boys club that he did
and so i text this guy and my friend one
of my best friends is blogging about it
and these are not things to
cry wolf about
and so i attacked him i'm like you okay
and he's like yeah i'm doing a prank
don't tell anyone
okay i'm like
okay cool i'll keep the joke going
so when are you going to tell everybody
he's like i'm not going to i'm like
well it's not really it's not really a
prank anymore then is it it's kind of a
scam
and a prank
so you're going to pre you're going to
say you got raided by the fbi and you're
not going to tell anybody he's like i
never said i got ready by the i'm like
oh the talmudic logic got it
and i've been sitting on that thinking
like
people are actually scared
you know people are actually afraid when
things like that happen people are like
oh big bear watch out they're coming for
truthers
you know they're coming for anybody
associated with this guy they're coming
they're coming they're not
it's a lie
all right and it's a boy who cried wolf
and it makes it so
you're just in a deception
and why would you do that to people and
then you look at these type of people
like um
and i'm not trying to do a gotcha thing
or call people out or anything i just
made me sick like it made me like sick
and by the way there's people that have
told me secrets that i've said i won't
say and i won't i keep my word
uh and i'd love to because i don't have
any secrets i've never burdened anyone
with a secret in my life but if you want
to just tell me about your disgusting
scams you're doing to people i'm the
wrong person to do that too i'm the
i'm big bear breaker of chains
okay that was corny but it was corny but
honestly
besides the cornball stuff he's not he's
right right i mean
i hate to do this
yeah
yes
yes oh
oh captain mike
do we have stand on our desk how does
this work are we supposed to stand on
our desks now
you know [ __ ]
so what is it owen [ __ ] redemption
arc not i guess so owen posted this text
correct yes okay uh supposedly
i think that's his
prank don't tell you're gonna reveal
it's a prank because i have friends
writing blogs about it never so you're
gonna pretend the fbi raided your studio
tons of people are texting me freaking
out i never said they did true did you
spill the beans look like you did we're
done
and now people are going after josh
denny they're going after uh [ __ ] daddy
wait
he supposedly was playing along with the
whole thing oh he was in on it
oh
so that guy doesn't have a leg to stand
on now
um [ __ ] man uh owen uh
owen's right i mean look i don't give
away some props here owen is a hundred
percent right you can't argue with that
there hold on did you think things would
get so bad that owens one of the good
guys
hear me out
i want you i'm going to throw this out
there everyone could tell me to [ __ ] off
but hear me out marsh
you know owen on rotc when let's bury
the hatchet rumble friday though because
that's rumble friday has to be invented
sit down with the boys okay here's what
we're doing because it's going to get
back to him because it always does so
here's what we're doing because he is
correct here and we want to be fair and
fair is fair so owen
we at rotc want to formally invite you
to come on the show hang out and maybe
talk a little bit maybe bear the hatchet
i'm just putting it out there this is
not a gotcha
this isn't a [ __ ] joke we're being
serious okay
there's any kind of a pledge to like oh
we're never going to goof on them again
no no no
but we i look i i have some things i
would like to on the air
concede to owen
so think about it he was ahead of the
curve with the cove and [ __ ] right he
happened to just [ __ ] be building his
weird little woodsman cult right around
the time they were burning the whole
planet down right
and now the gavin stuff ah i gotta you
know this you know i've said some bad
[ __ ] i got to say the good [ __ ]
so
it's out there i'm sure someone will
send it to him
being serious let's let's let's talk i i
really no [ __ ] it i mean i i want to
bury the hatchet with big bear we're big
bears so let's let's figure this out all
right what do you say
i mean i still think owen's [ __ ] nuts
but you know what
but i'd rather deal with nuts at this
point than folks but we've had people on
our show that are nuts that doesn't you
know what i mean yeah but everyone's so
full of [ __ ] and so few people are just
legitimately nuts yeah i'd rather deal
with the nuts